in Lambert Eaton syndrome
the immune system mistakenly attacks the
voltage-gated calcium channels in the
presynaptic terminal this leads to
muscle weakness which improves with
repeated exercise
in normal circumstances the vgcc leads
to calcium influx in the pre-synapse
that leads to the release of
neurotransmitter in the synaptic lift
this allows the postsynaptic
cationinflux which contracts the muscle
but in Norm in Lambert Eton syndrome the
vgccs are affected because the auto
antibodies that reduce the calcium
levels in the pre-synapse which further
leads to a reduction in the presynaptic
release leading to a weaker muscle
contraction and that's why there is a
muscle weakness
it is often associated with small cell
lung cancer it can be detected using
electromyography or via detecting